the jurogan experience does anybody want
to smell some smelling salts yes
last time i got to wake up
guys cleveland sold out this weekend
where are you promoting gigs we're
smelling smelling stuff in the middle
while you're getting ready because this
is going to make a video you [ __ ]
idiot and that video is going to be
everywhere and so the clue wouldn't take
it back but it's not cleveland this
weekend when this video goes around
because cleveland will be done
my ex was
had a real stank tangy veg i bet i can
take this no no no you cannot take this
spelling salts we'll go with norman
because he's cocky there's our
argefear.com i'll save them for okay
save it for later
ready now what is this powder you gotta
open it no it's like a crystal you gotta
open it up open it up but don't throw it
at me or anything when you i won't throw
it the smell hits you
[ __ ] freight train watch this
no way no no way wait you don't take it
like
smells
like powerlifter
don't take anything out
just take a step just take a sniff go
ahead ready here we go
bro you blew your neck out i heard the
back of my head
you blew your [ __ ] neck out my nose
bleeding have you done this before oh
yeah i did it with theo holy dick me and
theo did it the first time
look at our bigger nose
bigger nose stronger
old factory senses the biggest sensation
i bet ari's like a bloodhound i bet he
smells us different oh i'm tearing up do
you smell us different than we smell you
do you think i like the hell and i eat
ass
but the way he did that
like who the [ __ ] how can he do that
where's the top
i don't know down there bring that over
here
give it to daddy i'm snotting i'm
snotting oh my god i didn't hate he
stinks so bad i watched how did you guys
do how you want it i've only done this a
couple of times before but i remember
what it's like let's see if i've i've
like minimized it in my mind i went too
close to the bottle i think go
i was ready for it this time
it wakes you up
i feel cleared out oh [ __ ] i had covered
before that oh my god killed it it's so
surprising right yeah right i didn't
think it was like that
my ears popped it still hurts
it's very shocking even though i know it
i've done it already and you have to
keep it in this plastic bag um shout out
to uh how do you say his name jamie the
devil
yeah yeah right
yep you got it holy hell uh he's a a
power lifter dude who uh this is his
product and it's called ah right
it's called ah
like that's it's called that's fun
because that's what you do
you never hear about smelling pepper